des négociations tendues entre
washington et moscou sont en cours les
etats-unis et la russie s'affrontent sur
le sujet de l'ukraine et chaque camp
martèle ses positions le secrétaire
d'état américain anthony blinken a
déclaré qu'ils ne s'attendaient à aucune
avancée et a mis en garde le kremlin
contre de graves conséquences en cas
d'invasion de l'ukraine 1 2 kw h la
question est maintenant de savoir si le
président poutine empruntera la voie du
dialogue on cherchera la confrontation
l'otan se joint aux états unis pour
avertir la russie de sanctions sévères
toute nouvelle agression contre
l'ukraine aurait un prix politique
économique élevée
les alliés de l'otan sont unis dans leur
soutien pour que toutes les nations
choisissent leur propre voie mais alors
que des centaines de milliers de soldats
russes hamas à la frontière ukrainienne
moscou a ses propres exigences la russie
demande la signature d'un traité
incluant la garantie que l'ukraine ne
rejoigne jamais l'otan mais aussi le
départ de soldats américains des pays
d'europe de l'est
les etats-unis ont des bases militaires
sur tout le continent plus de 250 en
europe occidentale et plus d'une
douzaine à l'est les américains assurent
ne pas vouloir réduire leurs effectifs
et menacent de les renforcer si les
russes passent à l'offensive
de son côté l'union européenne appelle à
des sanctions contre moscou en cas
d'invasion washington a tenté d'assurer
à ses alliés européens qu'ils ne seront
pas mises à l'écart des pourparlers